Hi, everyone.
My name is Tyler Morgan-Wall.
I'm the developer of rayshader
and the rayverse.
And in the next 15
minutes, I'm going
to tell you how you
can turn your 3D data
visualizations into a theme
park ride entirely in R.
Now, before we get
started, I want
you to think back to the
very first theme park
ride or roller coaster
you ever went on.
I, for one, very clearly
remember my first roller
coaster ride because I was
7 and it was a disaster.
It was a bumpy, rough wooden
coaster that bruised my ribs
and rattled my spine.
And every hill, turn, and bump
is still ingrained in my mind.
Now, I don't have many
memories from when I was
seven, but that is one of them.
Now I want you to try to
think back to the first data
visualization you ever made.
It was probably something like
this, this, or God forbid, this.
But you probably don't remember
the first data visualization
you ever put together.
And that's because we tend to
remember things in our lives
that elicit an
emotional response.
My first roller
coaster ride
stuck with me because
of the emotions
it evoked, even if
they were negative.
Now, you might be
thinking, "well,
"data visualizations aren't
supposed to evoke emotion.
They're supposed to be
about informing the reader."
And to that, I'd like
to make an analogy
to another type of
institution that
needs to balance
fun and interesting
with informative and
educational: museums.
I like to look at
building a data
visualization like a museum
curating an exhibit.
Museums can have a bunch
of self-contained exhibits
that are static, small in scope,
and designed so that viewers
can digest the information
at their own pace, much
like most data visualizations.
But that doesn't mean
museums can't also
build a giant IMAX theater
or include a virtual reality
thrill ride, something that will
evoke a feeling of excitement
in patrons long after the
information from the placards
has faded from their memory.
So these are two pictures
from the Air and Space museums
here in DC. They have exhibits
that both inform and entertain.
And this isn't just conjecture.
Numerous studies have shown that
the most vivid memories tend
to be of emotional events, which
are recalled with more clarity
and detail than neutral events.
So while not every exhibit
should be a thrill ride, that
doesn't mean none can be.
I'm going to show you how
you can make experiences out
of your data
visualizations, how you
can turn ggplot into
a heart pounding ride.
Now, it doesn't necessarily
have to be a fast moving roller
coaster like this.
Yours might be more It's A
Small World than Space Mountain.
But I want you to have this
tool in your skill set,
and I'm going to show you how
you don't need any fancy 3D
modeling skills or Pixar
level animation skills
to make fun 3D rides.
So here's what you'll learn
in the next 12 minutes.
How to make a 3D roller
coaster in R, but why you will,
but also why you might want to.
But first, I'm going to
go over some basic ways
to make 3D plots in order that
don't require any fancy skills.
And I'll go over what
makes a good 3D data viz.
And finally, the
most common feedback
I get when I give a talk
on 3D data visualization
is, wow, I wish I could
make something like that,
but I don't work
with any 3D data.
So throughout this
presentation, I'm
going to give a bunch of
examples of 3D data
visualizations made from a
variety of different data sets
all in R that will hopefully
give you some inspiration
to try and make
something of your own.
Now there are a few packages
out there for 3D data
visualization.
But I'm going to talk
about the Rayverse,
the set of packages I
developed that focuses
on making high
quality 3D renders
with realistic lighting.
The main package I'll
be using in this process
is rayrender, a
package that enables
you to make beautiful path trace
3D visualizations entirely
in R.
The rayshader
package will be used
to transform your data
into 3D models using
either geospatial data or the
incredibly simple 3D ggplot
interface.
And finally, I wrote the
rayrollercoaster package
specifically for this talk.
It automates the entire roller
coaster construction process
down to two functions: one
to interactively build
your coaster and
another to animate it.
So let's cover the basics.
What exactly goes into a
3D data visualization?
First, what kind of data
can be used in 3D plots?
All you need for a 3D data viz
are data with at least
three numeric components.
Here we have European
flight path data
from the crowdsourced
OpenSky network.
Flight path data has latitude,
longitude, and altitude,
which intuitively correspond
to x, y and z
and are here
plotted as 3D paths.
This is a fairly straightforward
and intuitive use of 3D,
but you can also choose to use
3D aesthetics with 2D data,
much like you might choose a
line chart over a bar chart
purely for aesthetic reasons,
you might also choose a 3D
chart over its 2D counterpart
because you can make it more
interesting and visually
appealing.
This is a map of the submarine
fiber optic cable network,
and there's no actual
3D data present, just
latitude and longitude data.
The cables rise out of the
Earth where they start and fall
back in where they land.
You could easily plot this as
simple 2D paths on a world map,
but I think the floating
cables, subtle shadows
and rotating globe
really elevate
what is otherwise a fairly
simple data set into something
more relatable and tangible on
a human scale like the Earth
is being wrapped in yarn.
So, many 3D plots
have--or 2D plots
have direct 3D
equivalents, but just
replacing points and lines
with spheres and cylinders
can lead to mixed results.
Data floating in the void can be
hard to interpret if we're just
presented with a static image
as objects in the foreground
can block those
in the background,
as we see here in this
rendering of a morphine molecule
generated with
the raymolecule package.
But you can solve this problem
by animating the 3D data.
The movement disambiguates the
foreground from the background
so that the reader can fully
interpret the 3D model.
Besides points and lines,
the other main type of
3D data visualization
is the 3D mesh, a continuous
grid of data values.
This is where the rayshader
package comes in.
It takes 2D grids of raster
data and creates 3D models
by transforming the flat
matrix data into 3D.
So this visualization of the
underwater volcano, Hunga Tonga
that erupted earlier
this year was
generated from a simple 2D
matrix of bathymetry values
taken from a sonar survey.
Check out the code to
see how straightforward
this is-- from R matrix to 3D
model in just a few function
calls.
Now, this is true of almost
all of the visualizations
you'll see in this talk.
The rendering script
is usually only
a dozen or so lines of code.
Most of the work is in cleaning
the data, as it always is.
So when you're dealing
with non topographic data,
the process is similar.
You can convert the
previously 2D data
by extruding it into
the third dimension.
If you're having
trouble conceptualizing
what type of data can
be used for a 3D mesh.
One rule of thumb
is that any type
of data that can be mapped
to the fill or color
aesthetic and ggplot can
also be mapped to 3D.
Here we have a plot of
infections in John Snow's
famous cholera data
set, where the points
are colored by the number
of nearest neighbors
for each infection.
The process of
converting ggplots to 3D
is fully automated in
rayshaders plot_gg() function.
And if you want to
learn more information,
check out my R RStudio conf
2020 talk on making 3D ggplots
with rayshader.
So one reason you might consider
using 3D instead of color
is that encoding data to
color requires the viewer
to reference a color
bar to understand
the ordering of the data, as
there's no intuitive reason why
some colors correspond
to lower values
and some colors
correspond to higher.
Here, I plotted the
heights of buildings
in Seattle, Washington, by
mapping the data to color.
Height, on the other
hand, intuitively
allows you to judge which
values are less than or greater
than others.
You can tell when
a building here
is about half the
height of another
without having to reference
an external color bar.
However, because 3D introduces
ambiguity in the depth axis,
you lose precision.
Thus, 3D data visualizations
are great when
the exact numeric
values aren't important,
but comparing relative values
and getting an overall sense
of the distribution of data is.
Using both 3D and color can give
you the best of both worlds.
Color to indicate precise
numeric levels and height
to give a more intuitive
way to compare values.
Here we have a visualization I
made of the global population
density using both
color and height.
The use of color allows
the viewer to map data
to direct population intervals,
while the use of height
establishes order without
needing to reference a legend.
Now, if you're the
type of person like me
that likes to obsess over the
tiniest details of your data viz,
good news!
3D brings an entirely
new type of detail
to obsess about: lighting.
Move over, adjusting
ggplot margins.
If you've ever talked
to a photographer,
you know the real secret
to amazing photographs
isn't necessarily having
the best equipment,
but rather having adequate
and well designed lighting.
If you only have a single
light like we do here
in this 3D historical map, this
visualization is a bit spooky.
Like a swing light bulb
in a haunted house.
If you look at this
visualization of the blooming
California poppy fields, we
see--with multiple distant fill
lights, we see the atmosphere
has changed completely.
Much less moody
and much brighter.
Even easier than all of that
is using an HDR image file
for environment
based lighting, which
we see here in this
visualization of Monterey
Bay, California.
It lights the scene
with a real world image
which results in natural,
realistic lighting
like your scene was
in that environment.
If your data changes
over time, you
can then also introduce
animation to your data viz.
Here, I used a Microsoft
Kinect to capture my movements
and load them into R
using the RMoCap package.
By extracting the individual
time slices from the movement
data and rendering
each frame completely,
I was able to combine all the
frames into this animation
using the av package.
So watch out Pixar,
R users are coming for you.
[laughter]
You can even use this ability
to bring old friends back
from the dead. [applause]
Thank you.
So here I've used
R and rayrender
to bring Microsoft
Clippy back to life
to help you debug your
data analysis pipeline.
Maybe an idea for Posit's next
professional product.
[laughter]
And for the creatively inclined,
you can also produce
stunning generative art in 3D
using rayrender.
Here, I've simulated and plotted
the trajectory of a particle
in a strange attractor, a
type of differential equation
that displays chaotic motion.
I've lit the scene with
both a white and red light
and changed the
material of the object
to give it a glossy sheen.
We can also generate
fractal trees
using the raybonsai package.
This is a rewrite of Danielle
Navarro's flametree package
to work in 3D, and you can
create all different types
of trees with two or
three lines of code
all generated in R
with nothing but math.
And finally, unlike in 2D,
where there's only one way
to look at a
visualization, in 3D,
you have an infinite
number of camera angles,
orientations, and
settings to choose from.
It can be intimidating,
especially if you've never
worked in 3D before, but I've
made it a little less daunting
by including a fully
interactive, real time 3D to
graphics device
built into rayrender
and working out of the
box with no dependencies,
or no weird dependencies.
You can fly around your
scene with just your mouse
and keyboard and
find the best angle
and print out your camera
info for future use.
This is all happening
directly in your R session.
You can even interactively save
keyframes and then generate
an animation smoothly flying
through your data visualization
or, as I'm about to show
you, riding through it.
Now that you know everything you need
to know to make a 3D data viz in R,
let's build a roller coaster.
First, we need to generate a
3D scene for our roller coaster
to travel through.
Now, this could be any of the
visualizations I've shown up
to this point, but I'm going to
use a 3D ggplot because rayshader's
3D ggplot interface is
by far the easiest
way to make a slick
3D data viz in R.
This is a density plot
of the diamonds data
set in R with the fill
aesthetic mapped to 3D.
This is one function call,
passing the ggplot object, and voila!
A fully formed 3D data viz.
You might note that I've turned
off rayshader's ray tracing
because we're going to
get a much higher quality
version of ray
tracing when we render
the scene with rayrender.
Now that we have
our 3D scene set up,
here's where the rayrollercoaster
package comes in.
Here, all we need to do is call
the generate_rayshader_coaster()
function, which extracts
the rayshader scene for you
and automates the entire roller
coaster construction process.
This function uses rayshaders--
or rayrenders
built in interactive
graphics device
to let you fly around the
scene and build a roller
coaster directly in R.
Here, I've recorded
a video of myself
flying through the
scene pressing k
at the key positions
I want my roller coaster to
travel through. When I'm done
and close the window,
it will generate a 3D
model of a roller coaster
that travels through
those points.
Now I've extracted the full 3D
scene here with get_rayrender_scene()
and used render_scene() to
get an overhead isometric view
of the ride.
Sort of like Roller
Coaster Tycoon,
but with less death
and destruction.
Now that we're happy
with our roller coaster,
all that's left is simply
calling animate_rollercoaster()
with a movie file name, and
we get our full first-person
animated roller coaster ride
through our data set entirely
in R. Ta da!
[applause]
So we're all done creating
our roller coaster.
Or are we?
You see, while this is
cool, you might note
that it's more ride than data viz.
You can't look around
because the field of view
here is fixed at 120
degrees,
and the camera view is
stuck along the track.
If instead, we set the field
of view to 360 degrees,
we can render the entire scene
at every frame, which gives us
something that looks like this.
So this is rendering
a complete sphere
surrounding the
camera at every frame
so that we can see
every angle at once.
This allows the viewer
to choose where to look.
Now, this animation looks
rather funky and warped,
but we aren't going to
use the video in this form
because you can do
something very special
with 360 degree
videos by injecting
a little metadata to the mp4
file and uploading to YouTube,
You can turn this video into
a virtual reality 3D roller coaster
and put yourself directly
inside your data viz. [applause]
Now, the viewer can look
and direct their attention
to wherever they want as
they fly along the track.
Because you control
where you look,
it truly feels like
you're riding a thrill
ride with exciting,
vertigo inducing drops
and dizzying turns
that truly leaves an impression.
You don't need any fancy
VR gear to experience this.
I made this video with just my
phone and a $20 VR head mount,
and it only took a dozen
or so lines of code
to put together thanks to the
power of R and the rayverse.
So in summary, 3D plotting
is an awesome tool
you should consider trying out,
and there's no better ecosystem
out there for 3D
data viz than R.
Thanks to rayrender's
interactive render and the
rayrollercoaster package,
building an impressive thrill
ride through your 3D world
is dead simple and only
takes a few lines of code.
And finally, consider combining
the tools of virtual reality
with 3D data viz to immerse
your viewers on rides or tours
throughout your data.
By actually putting your viewers
in the data visualization,
you can form longer lasting
connections to your work
by evoking emotion
and allowing the user
to experience your visualization
in a more up close
and personal way.
Thank you so much for your
time, and enjoy the ride!